foreign
folks we might be drunk here we are
we're back we're doing it beard you what
are you doing here oh I'm on the other
side of the bar for once weird yeah you
know it's a little strange seeing my
ugly mug in front of the way in front of
the camera this time and not just my ass
while I'm delivering drinks yeah I've
always wanted to put like an ad sign on
there like you're out here right after
your two butt billboard you know right
yeah not a bad idea I'll charge 50 bucks
you put your uh your Law Firm on his ass
yeah it depends how much you pay we'll
do like a little tattoo over there too
like a little [__] stamp I'll hike up
the shirt that would be but we have to
do a thong in that
episode's on One Cheek right you know
that'd be a great reveal you sh you know
got a black shirt on you come out full
that's there we go yeah like what what
Realty what the hell is that
crack Realty Hey There It Is Well we
have a guest bartender today which is
exciting so beer juice going away for a
while and if you've been following the
patreon you know that we have been
taking submissions for people and uh
we're joined by Paulina Paulina
what's shaking
not much
um giving it a shot to see if you guys
like what do we what are we looking at
uh well I was told to make a paper plane
a Manhattan and I will be making a
Mezcal Negroni oh is that that's your
special that is my special yeah
that's my special welcome Paulie thank
you thank you quick Paulina what's your
favorite to tell bit oh come on don't do
it my favorite one David Talbot
um I don't know all right I am sorry no
I don't think that's normal telemanga is
trying to throw a wrench in the [__]
Wheels here why don't you give her a
second let her get comfortable there's a
little pad behind me a second ago
comfy did that fill the room yeah I took
the air out that fill the room
yeah I'm gonna try to be smelling a
Mezcal Negroni we have a classy drink
coming to us I'm gonna get a whiff of
Mark's ass sorry the turkey and the
avocado wrap yeah no I think that's like
the perfect I think that's the perfect
like uh Spectrum to like uh kind of see
like what the bars are I think on the
perfect perspective right now uh we're
all on technically we're on the spirit
because you have like hours like I guess
that's just our iconic drink now right
the paper plane and then uh because I
was gonna keep making appearances and
then I think that like one good like
classic drink like with Manhattan like
shows like how well that's my go-to
right exactly and like it shows like how
well you like know the classics and how
you can balance them out with like the
nice ingredients that we have and then
um uh then like I think like every bar
Center should be able to show like
they're kind of like not a signature
cocktail but show a little bit of
creativity because of like the guests
that we have here sometimes they'll have
like special requests you know like and
you have to like kind of work with it
and get a little funky you know she's
gonna get funky I like if you have a
Mezcal Negroni that's gonna I've had
them before and I think the the
smokiness of the Mezcal is is very nice
so I'm excited yeah I love that Negroni
is it's a spin on a Classics yeah yes
and the mascounter gronius have been
like really popping off recently in the
last like year that they've been getting
really really popular yeah also I think
Moscow in general is getting huge
[Music]
hit us up no but uh like you know how
every celebrity has a tequila now like
every single yeah I I am willing to bet
that within the next six months to a
year the next one that every celebrity
is going to be moving to is their own
Mezcal well the the Dos Hombres already
happened yes exactly the Brian Cranston
Aaron Paul guys which I tried it at an
airport lounge because I don't love
myself and uh pretty good yeah that was
a pretty good Mezcal Fort Wayne Airport
you got to put them back apparently you
think they have a lounge in Fort Wayne
good point apparently Aaron Paul like
took a lot of he really dove into that
like personally and Brian Cranston was
talking about that he goes you know I
know nothing about this but Aaron Paul
like really got into it like yeah he's
like he was the you know know the
Heisenberg of this mascara like he was
like he was really got into it went to
visit Oaxaca and the uh let's tell you
that's a good way to get away with being
an alcoholic like what are you been on a
better for six months I'm testing
Tequilas I'm working them all out I am
the one who sips yeah nice I mean that's
my that's my that's been my excuse for
the last what almost a year and a half
two years they're like what are you
doing Dan it's 11. I'm a researcher
there you go I got an episode tomorrow I
love what she's doing and Manhattan is
what I make when I'm on the road I mean
I've been lucky enough to Bodega cat in
The Green Room we sold a bunch of them
at these theater dates they were selling
them in the crowd it's fun I'm doing my
crowd work we they can't do you know in
theaters I'm used to having waitress or
waitresses running the drinks the tables
when I'm doing crowd work they can't do
that so my tour manager Brian is his
Syracuse nearly knocked the camera over
my tour manager Brian is running with
Bodega cat cocktails to give to people
like this guy's a full service manager
you know yeah and uh but before they a
show I'm making my own little Bodega cat
Manhattan sure on the Rocks you serve it
up usually well that's awesome
we share oh yeah I love it
great yeah yeah yeah those are some nice
February cherries behind there as well
what do you think about this idea thank
you all these celebrities are making
Liquors Monica Lewinsky could make the
mayonnaise
or what about just like a speckled dress
clothing line yeah
[Music]
tide pin yeah she really missed the boat
on that one Monica Lewinsky's jizz stick
all right who's dated yet 38 year old
joke sorry what whose joke was that
where it's like he's like Bill Clinton
found the only Jewish girl who couldn't
get a stain out like was it like the
only Jewish girl that [__] sucks a
dick
I don't know I was on prove me wrong
ladies prove me wrong I found that
they're very giving women I agree no
there's no sexual Guild like with the
Catholic [__]
um who won't we piss off this week guys
why don't we have more female viewers
what was the Jewish app it was it like
chosen PayPal you mean no no no
yeah I would go on Jayden my signal Jay
swipe that was it I go on j-swipe and go
uh willing to convert and I cleaned up
because I was like exotic it's a good
one I was a [__] but you know they
thought oh I can change him but
I did one time I was on J swipe and
Rachel Feinstein takes my phone and
starts just messaging people with
horrible pickup lines because she thinks
it's funny it's my life
she messages one woman she goes she goes
uh uh you a naughty little girl that
needs to be tamed me a bad boy who
doesn't play by the rules and she writes
back me a comedy producer you a comic
who's doing my show next week
oh
Jesus Christ how was the show Awkward
that was sex terrible
ah damn wow that's wild yeah but you
know she can see the comic she gets it
and you can blame it on Rachel yeah she
wasn't a comic she's a producer oh okay
we're playing so who we started beard
you have to start I think because you
are these you're the Simon I mean look
at your shirt right now I keep wearing
the same shirt
well yeah I mean the muscle shirt right
I'll be Randy Jackson
beautiful I guess that makes me Paula
let's do it all right you got a blow
seal can you pull up Simon Cowell now
have you seen his face these days it's
pretty wild
what do you got paper plane Mark you try
it now all right pass it down let's just
do one at a time paper plane
do you how often do you make these
Paulina is a paper plane in your
rotation yeah I mean I bruh yeah pretty
often I
know that's nice very nice no nice it's
very very well balanced smooth as hell
very nice
so it's a little it's a little like uh
smoother not as like acidic I prefer the
orange peel yeah it's nice same yeah
good call
where where do you bought do you bartend
uh in the winter I don't I bartend in
Montauk in the summertime like a few
years that I've been doing that
initiated the last bar was Continental
um
I've been there the five shots for ten
dollars that was a real college spot oh
yeah you must have seen some [__] over
there yeah I spent no idea you're like a
[__] you're like a UFC fighter who
like trains in in a bar fight in Russia
yeah it's basically I'm covered patient
zero
that's basically like working in the bar
version of a waffle house right right
it's like okay on your resume okay can
you throw hands you gotta fight Dennis
right now just to make sure like Mulaney
had that old bit about like I think
we'll die if we go to Nickel shot Knight
I always assume that was about the
Continental because they had that crazy
deal yeah it's like it's all like sugar
shots and stuff right is that uh is that
guy from like the Raiden Mortal Kombat
hat still out there
shut down a couple of years ago he's
still around in the village he opened an
ice cream shop
ice cream shop she's known to be the
raiding hot guys
what is with the hat why do you wear
that well he's been I don't know he wore
it every day for
years I worked there for six years
trigger is what he goes for trigger yeah
trigger and I don't know covering his
face gorgeous
yeah
Pauline did you use the the carpano
Antica for the Manhattan uh we're gonna
pull up the Continental too yeah
it's gonna work oh that's lovely too
very nice this is the this is which
Manhattan
very nice
all right now is it just like a like a
Barnard thing I'm just curious how much
I don't usually do it three quarters
very nice is that the Undertaker
yeah
as well oh thank you in the back like in
the over in the back over there I can't
find our guy I will say I prefer
Manhattan on the Rocks but this is very
good very good
Paulina P dog yes
I mean two for two I would say two for
two and this is the big one yeah this is
the message
oh baby this is it the big reveal you
got time to Paulina you got time to
clean huh
we'll count it
look at this guy there he is
yeah that guy's carried me out of there
a few times yeah
oh my God what
is lovely that's nice it's Smoky I love
the Smoky well each of those people have
right before it does he goes finish him
finish it then leave yeah dude the smell
alone is trigger that's nice yeah what's
up with the ice cream place he owns now
is it full I've already closed that
windows
I used yours yeah yeah yeah this is a
really good drink I would try to sell
America it's not like it's not overly
smoky it's just there it's really good
yeah just enough smoke this is a father
going to pick up his child doesn't give
you a hangover at school apparently yeah
I'll tell you it doesn't give you a hand
yeah exactly
you like that very nice we also have
like a we have like a torture there's a
bunch of little toys you can like flame
out oranges and stuff if you're if
you're comfortable with that I've been
drinking naturally because this butane
torch right here I mean we're on the
tour bus and I've been drinking a lot of
natural wine with the boys and we are
getting like look at me lit up you
turned me on to that yeah I'm now doing
that
there's no hangover what is it why
that's so funny I guess
put it in the other one I don't know but
it's pretty damn good we were getting
lit up so we're on the tour bus we're
getting wasted and uh you know veter's
the only one who doesn't drink but it's
me James Brian the tour manager we're
getting drunk and uh watching Something
About Mary great Tour Bus movie watch I
[__] up the next night I was like
we're not getting to see the Oscar picks
let's watch something artsy we watched
the movie tar on the tour bus
cable and [__] not a tour bus movie
no she's a she's a maestro yes yes it's
a the Slow Burn and the whole time
Gary's going [__] you
this movie sucks and James is you know
in those shots so James like it's it's a
slow but you know but Gary is like I'm
watching him we have to like you know
ease him off it with like you know he's
like someone's on painkillers coming off
we had to ease him off it with [__]
uh it's always sunny episodes afterwards
he was in a bad mood dude you know how
it's over you guys have the drunk Haze
of like ah we can get through this yeah
you know like when you get drunk on a
plane it's different yeah similar like
on a bus well I'll tell you we I was
shocked at how well we did with it
because we're on this tour bus and we're
getting you know lit up but we we slept
like babies on that bus like oh you need
to sleep yeah well I get little baby
Gary
no we we were animals on there I was
getting messages from Liz she goes how
dare you just abuse Gary like this
because we'd have James doing like you
know tricep extensions on the uh on the
top bunks you know he's just always
working out yeah well he's doing it he's
like farting and garagebunk we're just
animals
four Dudes on a bus what do you expect
yeah about those bunks like for you for
your your tall guy do you fit how long
are those bunks
if I was like six five instead of six
three I wouldn't fit so I'd be [__]
you can't say you'd be [__] you know
what else I did in a [__] trailer
behind it yeah
if you open your window put your feet up
look up hug sleep I bought this
compression blanket
um and it like wraps you in a [__]
thing you sleep like [__] a mummy
you're like this uh and I was like hell
I don't like you but it makes me sleep
on my back but then in the middle of the
night I have to get up and I have to use
the bathroom uh it looks like I'm a drag
I'm walking in the bathroom like hello
boys yeah George Santos over here
wow see I don't like the constriction
it's but it feels good when you're
sleeping I like a weighted blanket but
not somebody that will wrap me up what
do you guys it's the same effect what's
going on here get a regular blanket
I have I hate it
selling weighted blankets were you
molested I don't like it for you
Colin yeah what am I a toddler or a
molested victim in all fairness that
does look like Gary
pull up a picture of little garyvee you
throw some glasses on that kid it's over
I put a joke book next to him there he
is same guy yeah you know my therapist
actually has a sidekick bad at me on
she's like were you molested here's a
coupon there you go the old molested
discount what about uh
but the bus is nice it does it has said
that gurgle of a bus really is uh good
for sleeping oh Gary I always loved
falling asleep on like the passenger
trains like the long time in Ukraine
like I used to have to go like three
days and we'd have like a compartment
right and that was like the best way to
sleep because you feel like the track's
just like that's kind of how it feels
you're kind of you are getting rocked to
sleep a little it's funny I was asking
that I got I got really lucky our bus
driver actually was the same bus driver
we had years ago when I was opening for
Aziz so he remembered me and he goes I'm
so proud of you that you're now it's
your show it's your best now so and he's
a really nice guy Jeff and uh it's funny
he's eating pickles during the drive and
I was like why do you Pickles he goes
because it keeps me up whoa the the
assist Popeye that's spinach [__] I mean
it smells like Gatorade it's like
electrolytes like you're good is it
really but it's pickles it's all sodium
okay I don't like the idea it was a
driver being kept up by pickles like
this is the thing keeping him awake I
didn't like that he was deep throating
them but I thought it was all right but
uh no he he was eating pickles and he
was a really cool guy and uh I mean we
lucked out for sure I mean we thought
how funny it would be if we just opened
we just opened the door to see him
driving and he's just like you're in
Columbus we're like no
head off
but we uh no he was he was great you
know he drove really well but I'd say
which are the bad roads they say Texas
roads are easy but Missouri sucks and I
was like [__] I felt it while I was
sleeping
yeah they're harder to drive very
disorienting too when you hit bumps and
you're like where am I who am I what
state am I in you're all over the place
but you wake up in a new city there's
something pretty cool that's the best
you just cut out of course the one day
we fly home our flight gets canceled
you know but uh we you know we wake up
every day was like we're in Tulsa today
we're we did the they did the pizza
Guinness uh World Records thing so
there's 25 of the best pizza makers in
the country Professor Pizza this guy uh
Tommy who runs the place [__] it's
called the DeMarco slice in Tulsa it's
top five slices of my life no it's
unfucking real Tulsa Pizza is incredible
he's a New York guy really Tulsa and or
maybe Jersey but he's like he's an East
Coast guy and uh also Oklahoma yeah okay
wow dude next level Kane's Ballroom
which is where the Sex Pistols punch the
hole in the wall there's so much like
legendary [__] there
all right Tulsa oh dude that pizza is
one of the best slices of my life if
you're in Tulsa Tulsa's the new
Connecticut
yeah kind of it's like a Mad Lib did you
in Tulsa with the pizza it's like a game
of Clue oh what was the name of the
pizza place again
called DeMarcos of uh Demarcus of
Brooklyn no but it's closer dude I think
this isn't Tulsa it says in oh
Andolini's Pizzeria that's it yeah I
wonder if those mob ties or something
like how did they get from Brooklyn to
Tulsa I bet that's mob related yeah
there's there's a huge outside of the
Gambino family in Oklahoma I'm trying to
promote this guy's business marks
no I'm not saying he is but that's how
he got there a couple Generations before
him fishing it's not the answer no we uh
yeah no we really a great pizza we're on
the bus we see it we're in St Louis we
end up seeing Chris Rock You Know
amazing hanging with us in the hotel it
could have been cooler and then uh
because we're in the same hotel lobby in
St Louis we end up seeing his show his
new material is phenomenal I can't wait
he's so it's crazy to see a guy that
good in an arena sometimes Arena Comics
don't have hard jokes a lot of swagger
yes Rock it's like all these big Ideas
it's kind of unbelievable and it covers
the Will Smith stuff he's got an Elon
Musk chunk it's great it's great oh he's
he's actually doing the wheels now he's
got like he's had enough time to flush
it out and then uh and then last night
and then I land and I see Colin Quinn's
new one-man show how was it was it
unbelievable oh I can't wait and if you
haven't listened to the Colin Quinn
episode of this listen to it but Colin
Quinn's new show Small Talk of the Lucio
lortel star-studded uh oh yeah Seinfeld
was there whoa is that opening night
then yeah yeah why'd you go I had a gig
in Jersey a one-nighter I forgot about
it but I got tickets re-up for next week
but I missed the big the big to do I
think the people that care make it a
point wow but I had tickets I just
forgot about the guys like I'll see you
tonight I was like
I forgot all about it we sold it out so
I had to go I gotta go do a show in
Newark it's important but list is like
we're all going to Quinn where are you
I'm like uh I saw a list I'm in Morris
Plains yeah uh how was that so you had a
whole group yeah but uh Marlon craft the
rapper came with me he's my plus one
pure New York guy if you don't know
Marlon Craft's music he's phenomenal so
look up his music uh Spotify he really
blew up in the last couple years he took
that picture he and his music's in our
and me and salacus is uh doc Julius
Randle yeah so many great songs cocky
humble great rapper anybody talk to
Seinfeld you see Dr Jerry I didn't I
don't know him you know him but did you
go hey there's Jerry wait I wouldn't say
anything though all right how far away
was he he was he was Far okay
far enough Entourage I think it was just
him and his wife wow man of the people
man of the people Hamilton's opening at
the Beacon all week yeah I saw that
pretty cool Ryan Hamilton great comic
great comic oh there you go
like real throwback uh beats like very
jealousy Soulful soulful
he's it was dad's a jazz musician you
can almost like feel that in his rap
it's like very old school like plays The
Vibes is that what his dad does plays
The Vibes I don't know I think so that's
a nice apartment
this is what I couldn't do about rap
this is why I'm a comedian this [__] I
can't do
any like this I just can't do those
movements and live with myself after I'm
like
what am I doing
I'm not knocking it I just can't do it
it's rappers and dudes in wheelchairs
[Laughter]
for that Always Sunny episode where uh
it's like d is dating or something yeah
I think I moved a lot of those episodes
one's still up but it's still up because
that's a great app because at the end he
like freestyles and goes do you really
think I'm mentally just say that he like
he has like a beautiful like amazing
like uh like Freestyle track that he
just disses her on in front of everybody
yeah but just because like he does this
thing they're like obviously oh that's
hilarious it's funny it's like that you
can't even say [__] anymore but that
was the title of the episode really I
think it was she's dating a [__] guy
the office had a whole [__] episode
I think they might have just like uh put
in like mentally [__] not just
it's the same exact thing but you put an
extra word now you're a nice guy it's
all so silly it's also arbitrary
yeah hey good I'm just saying guys you
guys who just agree with each other
colored person person of color what are
we doing here it's awesome whose joke
was that it's like that uh uh
uh it's better to put the
um
the curse oh it was Bill Burr I think or
yeah it was Bill Burr yes it's better to
put the first thing before or after oh
yeah you know black guys [__]
Asian [__] [__] Asian yeah
that's a great Point that's a great bit
damn it but all the [__] we're saying
now will be offensive at some point so
you just gotta you just gotta go go nuts
is gonna be the new n-word I'm calling
it gonna get those shirts Mark calls his
agent you're gonna kill me
cut the merch
take off the hard cue yeah
sorry all right Paulina I think these
were absolutely delicious I can't put
this down this hamez cow delicious and I
think the orange twists on the paper
plane is a really good touch uh who do
you want to sleep with the least
don't answer that uh
that's gonna be something you can't say
but ask a question on an interview yeah
who's gonna get the first lawsuit um yes
all right so uh where can the people
find you
um are you on social media and all that
stuff yeah what about your address
is my where are you from originally
Mexico City uh Florida
that's a good pull nice I like that so
that's where the Mezcal Negroni comes
from right yeah there we go are your
parents in Mexico City uh yeah yeah nice
I've been uh in New York for 10 years so
pretty newish yeah yeah so yeah I wanted
to do Mezcal see if you guys liked it
fantastic is it true that they aren't
allowing New Yorkers to live there for
over a month
yeah wow isn't that wild we got we were
so we came in so hot here in covid and
we took over here no
no good story pull it up really yeah
they were they were like you can't stay
that long they kept moving there to
Mexico City it's such a cool City it is
it's awesome and they were like this
you're ruining a culture because it's
all these New Yorkers now yeah Trump
wants to build a wall they're going to
keep us
when I went there a few years ago like I
I lived in Brooklyn I lived in Bushwick
and we would we touched down and we
touched down in like Roman Norte and we
looked around like did we just take like
a round-trip flight back because like
everybody in Bushwick speaks Spanish
anyway right uh and Roman orders just
looked exactly like Bush were like this
is great we're back home it was
fantastic except with better food and
better Moscow right I mean 2020 is when
it got crazy because it's a lot of
people yeah I'm sure yeah it's downtown
the one thing that got me was the the
altitude I didn't realize about the
altitude oh really yeah um we went out
like uh my girl and I went out drinking
and we had like a cool bartender give us
like a flight of Mexico and we're both
bartenders we drink a lot we have
ridiculous tolerance right but we had
like a small flight like maybe five like
little like the saucers and then we get
up and we're just bombed and you know we
get apparently do we get drugged or
whatever blah blah we find our way back
to the Airbnb and I start looking it up
like oh it's just like the altitude like
you metabolize alcohol slower yeah you
know frappos a good amount to they're
going to use that in a second they'll be
like they're gonna roof you a girl like
it's the altitude
we're in Denver it's not just what I
slipped into your drink yeah what uh so
from Mexico City you've been here what
is lie or Saloon it's a bar that
shutdown as well that's two for you that
yeah
oh my God you're gonna leave here it's
just gonna burn down
um but yeah I was at liar Saloon in
Montauk all right but I live in the city
I just go in the summertime spend a few
months and work out there what do you
think worst city than Mexico City or or
better New York
it's just New York is my love oh but I
mean I love Mexico City but it's you're
not in love with it New York City it's
an X yes there you go you're here all
right well Paulina great job
thank you guys we loved it nice to meet
you Paulina oh nice to meet you guys
yeah what do you got work tonight
I think you're unemployed possibly
homeless
sounds like a hard-working partner go
back to my car yeah
all right well geez thanks for coming in
you killed it great stuff thank you so
much Paulina uh
all right all right resetting hey folks
feel like your best self in 2023 with
liquid IV I got about 9 000 bags of this
stuff I got to bring it in here because
we're putting the booze down in just one
stick you get five essential vitamins
and two times faster hydration than
water alone my favorite flavor is the
strawberry very good tastes good Goes
Down Easy use it first thing in the
morning before a workout when you feel
run down or after a long night out or on
Long flights
I love it I drink a lot we both do so
might as well put one in you get those
vitamins and nutrients going because uh
Lord knows that poison will take it out
of you
free from gluten dairy and soy it
contains the three electrolytes uh three
times the electrolytes as traditional
sports drinks uses cellular transport
technology designed to enhance rapid
absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream baby
grab your liquid IV and bulk nationwide
at Costco or you can get 20 off when you
go to liquid iv.com and use code drunk
at checkout that's 20 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code drunk at liquid
IV
dot com nothing makes you sound smarter
than learning a new language Babel is a
language learning app with easy
bite-sized language lessons uh I mean
this is we all want to learn another
language we've had people like Veer
Dawes on here who sound cultured as hell
oh yeah it's always nice to know another
language you go to another place you
don't have to go speaky American
because what I do currently so get on
Babel you know lessons take as little as
10 minutes a day so you start having
real life conversations in as little as
three weeks choose from 14 different
languages with lessons voiced by real
native speakers not computers with Babel
you can access podcasts Games videos
stories and even live classes to help
you on your way plus it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee right now
get up to 55 off your subscription when
you go to babel.com drunk that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash drunk for up to 55
off your subscription Babble language
for life
baby all right save time and have the
energy you need to tackle everything on
your to-do list with factors ready to
eat meals delivered straight to your
door Factory shops preps cooks and
delivers to your door so you can enjoy
Chef crafted dietitian approved minus
the hassle they sent me a bunch of these
things they taste great there's all
kinds of different flavors fish steak
chicken with veggies and sides I loved
it and they give you these smoothies too
you just get a big assortment of fruit
smoothies you got the greens you got the
berry you got the veggie with calorie
smart and keto options Factor meals are
perfectly portioned to keep you on track
with your goals with over 34 meals per
week and over three dozen add-on options
each factor meal arrives pre-prepared by
their chefs come on ready to eat and eat
in two minutes
head to factormeals.com
drunk60 and use code drunk60 to get 60
off your first box that's a lot that's
code drunk 60 at factormeals.com
drunk60 to get 60 off your first box
Factor get on it hey boys since
manscaped has already made your balls
nice and fresh it's time to do something
about that face that ugly mug manscaped
has just announced a brand new beard
hedger Pro kit good to mix those up you
don't want to shave your face with
something that smells like your taint
the beard hedger gives you 20. uh hair
cutting links all at the turn of a dial
no more changing out attachments and
it's waterproof so you can shave in
Katrina and since manscape wants you to
have all the tools for the job they're
throwing in a beard brush comb scissor
just to make you look like a million
bucks tell them how fat eight get 20 off
and free shipping with the code drunk at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping at
manstatemanscape.com and use code drunk
the manscaped beard hedger Pro kit the
premier solution to face grooming yeah
that was fantastic no seriously really
thank you
Rock and we got our second uh bartender
I mean is this beard you 2.0
[Music]
so if I'm the beer Jew and I'm not
Jewish at all he's the wine [__] no no
he's Jewish
yeah that's what I'm saying that's what
I should have been this dude would have
killed Nazis yeah I would have done my
best yeah oh yeah with your hands I
could see you holding an ax I like a
bartender who looks like if [__] it push
comes to shove he's gonna throw someone
a [__] headlock
he looks like he eats juice it's crazy
you are one I could see uh you just it's
just full devouring now what's going on
here he brought a gift in this is really
greasing the wheels a little bit I love
it I appreciate it we take forever and
I'm gonna crack it right now a lot of
cigars yeah we'll keep this in studio in
case someone has a baby
[Music]
I think so I've got three out there now
yeah sorry but you don't pay for the
supporters no no they're on the street
good
for a cup of coffee the price of a cup
of coffee
all right A lot of people always do that
like why are you giving us an example of
something that I can't live without
right with the price of a cup of coffee
I need the coffee oh good point save for
the price of like a small fries right
right I need the coffee every day that's
a great point
making some good points
you're over it oh yeah so you got the
Knicks game tonight is that right yeah
next cab what are we playing oh yeah
Cavs Cleveland's good all right LeBron's
on there right like just kidding you
left the Cavs
ooh baby maybe give me the big boy give
me that silver
oh this is great it's like Christmas
look at that are you a big cigar guy
Mark not big but I like uh I like one of
one a month
listen to that hold on let me get the uh
hear that at Home Folks that's the sound
of a nice Cuban getting toasty
look at that I love that type of lighter
there's something about that type of
lighter that just looks badass yeah and
that flame the huge view stands yeah
love fire
[Laughter]
I feel like I won uh the craps table
here
so where do you uh where do you bartend
uh it's called Uh 1776 in Morristown New
Jersey isn't that one of those though in
the uh in the village or am I making but
I did there could be it's a David Burke
restaurant
it was a steakhouse or something
um it's not a steak I mean he David
Burke is known for his uh his beef his
steaks and things like that but it's not
like necessarily a steakhouse it's like
it's like an American kind of uh place
all right so yeah my friend used to work
in one of those and he would hook it up
oh really he would hook us up with
drinks yeah nice and just so the
internet doesn't say I'm sexist what's
your favorite Bill Burr skit or bit my
favorite Bill Burr bit bit you're
bombing with this uh section here this
favorite bit I know you're testing them
which I appreciate
but uh I don't know if people have a
favorite bit I do so it's uh so my
favorite Bill Burr is from his new
special
um Red Rocks yep it's the one where he's
talking about
um it's his abortion piece oh and he's
like um he's like listen
you just call it what it is I support it
but it's murder you know and he has a
great analogy about the cake in the oven
so good I saw him work that out for the
first time at the Patrice benefit no wow
that was pretty cool to see that Joe
Crush
for that crowd and then it's you know
it's in the special but yeah that was a
great special amazing how fun is that
Patrice thing the new Patrice ones March
fourth yeah it's always in March it's
coming up yeah it's coming up soon yeah
he's announced it always a fun lineup
Rich Voss hosted every year it's it's
always great
yeah classic show and yeah I was gonna
call you a sexist but uh you really
pulled it together
no that's uh
impressive yeah that was good so what is
this the paper plan paper plane oh baby
in the big Martin
users
I like but that's how I like it because
that way you're not [__] you're not
Michael J foxing all over yourself
that's why that's why I like the coop
classes the curved ones that yeah
because it kind of like lets you slots
around those yeah yeah but the martini
glass just looks cool they do look yeah
that's a little dainty we're being
honesty I look like a lord I don't like
it yeah yeah
very nice oh yeah
paper plane number two
second tower
okay
very nice very nice let's see that one's
a little lighter too that was a little
lighter
foreign
that's a 10 out of 10 right there that's
a damn good paper plan I should put the
cigar out on Paulina
I'm joking but whilst Alex you asked her
her favorite to tell me
someone's gonna chop up there's that
part
they're sexist uh I love you Paulina
this Paulina was great yeah she's very
good this is a this is a damn good very
good that is an amazing don't knock over
the camera this time
I'm glad you enjoy it very good real Jew
is killing it yeah
real Jew the only thing I would say is
that I think you already know but a
cocktail is never complete without a
garnish so oh
I don't know should be a knife there so
I know somebody took it away never mind
well that was just being kind of comfy
right now
I like how I like having a picture of
Simon Cowell just in the corner he's the
real G you're the beer Nazi now yeah
become the beer Nazi yes there you go
either die you either die quick or live
long enough to become the villain Gray
Goose stepping
all right
what do we so this is the Manhattan now
oh baby I do love a Manhattan Manhattan
the most uh uh
[Music]
damaged in movies history damaged like
the most uh ruined movie oh most Brewing
City in movies
yeah
blown up fire catch uh you know a
pandemic
murderers uh aliens do a pretty good job
ourselves on that yeah I'm guessing L.A
comes next I guess La would be next yeah
but Manhattan's number one
you know it's Ghostbusters it's uh
what's that Will Smith movie Legend
Escape From New York Escape From New
York the movie Manhattan he destroys the
high school girl
[Music]
a lot of rooms there you go I'll tell
you good City really seems to occur day
after tomorrow there is another one I
love that movie by the way you're the
one
yeah
I think it was a big thing I don't like
disaster movies you know which one is
faster that's the worst I don't like
some of all fears that was a real
[__] turd you ever see that one Ben
Affleck and Morgan Freeman they nuke the
Super Bowl what in Baltimore yeah yeah
whoa they do it no I don't know who
nukes
Leo Nazi the starter War fascists to
start a war between America and Russia
and they're like we gotta get rid of the
Browns
Cleveland
[Laughter]
they get Deshawn Watson who's got all
this bad press and he stinks
yeah when no one can give him a massage
now that he's on the sidelines he cramps
up he needs help all right
I'm excited to try this Manhattan this
is living we got Drake's coming doggies
yes this is a regular wrap oh yeah this
is fun no sorry Peters you've been
overruled yeah you just thought this
might be a patron I'm having a good time
no this is too fun we got it's a it's an
action app this stuff happening you know
I really I really like it on this side
of the bar it's a lot more fun
this was his last show
that plane's not coming back from Bali
yeah he goes in the Next Room we're
making you a regular no
[Laughter]
oh it's like the yeah
in the pay phone I got him [__]
that's good stuff you carry somewhere I
don't wanna right behind you there
should be a good question
yeah there you go there we go the
garnets won't happen I'll say this and
don't clip this against me but sometimes
being a Nazi can have good results
[Music]
you see old videos of Alex Jones he's
kind of like a handsome he was ripped
yeah he looked like Bill Hicks a little
bit Yeah he was a hunk
all right guys here's the Manhattan oh
oh no ice
yep thank you sir you're messing with me
this time let me see Pop that chair
you're the Manhattan connoisseur
look at that that was Alex Jones it's a
good drink I will say and this is no no
fault against you no points against you
but I do prefer Manhattans on the Rocks
I always like them well I mean like yeah
I I know you do but I would say that's a
perfect preference but everyone makes
them this way yeah if you don't give him
your preferences yeah you gotta say on
the rocks for sure but don't you agree
they're kind of better on the Rocks I
honestly I do not I really I really like
them up because
um like once you once it's mostly about
the sweet vermouth like once this once
you have ice in there in the water it
kind of separates the sweeper moves and
then you have this weirdly layered drink
rather than like uh you know
um a fully integrated like fully uh
mixed drink and then you get all the
flavors at the same time with it with
with the with the Rocks like unless
unless wait okay unless you have a big
Cube unless you have a nice one a little
Cube yeah if you have a nice like large
Rock then yes absolutely I want a hard
yeah Hard Rock Cafe Dwayne Johnson I
want to throw in yeah no I love that no
I like a big rock in there for sure I
like the Rocks sorry rocks too iced too
very nice Jones yeah yeah he's hot
looks like Tim Dillon on roids
[Laughter]
never forget the garnish
that's what I listened to before I go on
stage I have to pump myself up that
voice when you start talking like that
conspiracy theories it's not good for
your mental health no it takes a toll
yeah and when you start hating the Jews
is when you're like all right you just
went nuts you know it's always coming
well especially if you're on TV you know
yeah oh yeah true I don't know what that
means I don't know whether they control
the media was that what that was yeah
yeah I got it this was his last show
this was his last show he's done I'm
trying to help you there no I'm just you
know I'm just pulling out a little stop
since it is the last show yeah
he's holding it pretty tight over there
keeping this in this whole time and the
whole time I'm the real Nazi
uh how tall are you there sir six three
okay and he's like and he's like a
strong six three dude this guy's a
[__] o-line well no I'm I'm wearing
I'm wearing Tims
did you play football I didn't I played
baseball oh no position uh Third Base
damn you're guarding that line
favorite third baseman uh David Wright
oh Mets man dude he's got all the
answers respect right I'm a Yankees fan
but I love David right favorite Dave
Wright bit
oh the time the time he uh broke his
back and left and left the Mets forever
oh wow no that's a heart that was a hard
dark wow I love it that's a dark side
but that's offensive but that's a Mets
fan sense of humor you got that right
you have to laugh you gotta be dark
maybe you guys get ohtani next year you
never know that'd be eight the baseball
fan I mean I like it uh I think I think
the Mets is this off season did it are
actually they're glad they didn't get
Correa yeah no no I I wanted I wanted
Korea I was kind of disappointed when uh
that fell through but I mean with uh
with Brett Beatty and uh and Escobar we
have like a solid Third Base already so
like we'll be fine you know yeah that's
what you need in a bartender you need to
be able to talk sports that's true you
need to be able to talk everything yeah
good point therapists Sports
uh make a mean cocktail I don't know
what he's making right now but I'm
excited to try it okay
there you go oh my God I gotta wreck for
you guys by the way speaking of gimlet
because it just made me think of her uh
Lauren Bacall
her book
oh it didn't like I'm literally talking
about Hollywood royalty you can't keep a
[__] farting come back
no but literally okay so listen to the
audiobook though because her voice is
hilarious she's literally like and then
Kirk Douglas came over and have his way
with me and I was in a cloud
she keeps saying I was on a cloud oh I
love the old timey [__] her romance
with Humphrey Bogart incredible stories
why do people talk like that back then I
don't know but I love it I like it too
what's your name uh you know the same
reason that people talk with like vocal
fry now is just like that's bad you know
what I mean well you're right you're
right who's the other one I'm thinking
of uh that Cape land [__] played in The
Aviator you know what I'm talking about
oh Catherine Hepburn oh she also had
that voice I love that she did yeah
no
it sounds like the mom on the critic
yeah
that's a deep cut look at Kevin
fun guy wide tie she was just like a
classy cool holiday I smoked she was fun
and she's very witty very witty witty
and funny and cool and classy and the
stories are incredible it's like about
Howard Hawks and right I have not
meeting bogar it's it's a good it's a
good audiobook like when it's a really
good performer you want you want to hear
the audio right so true
um Dana Carvey in his Heyday remember
his old stand-up was so good oh this is
gonna be a great game nice but this is
this is a gimlet [__] again
Dana Carvey had the bit where he said uh
Catherine Hepburn sounds like a car not
starting on a cold day
[Laughter]
George Clooney of his day that's a great
movie Philadelphia Story
oh it's uh Jimmy Stewart and Cary Grant
it's a it's a funny it's a great job
super smooth what's in that again what's
a gimlet so it's it's uh vodka in this
case I use Tito's and lime juice and
simple syrup damn nice and easy honestly
I'm so dumb I didn't even know there was
simple syrup and I thought it was just
lime juice so so okay so this is the
thing with gimlets like uh old school
gimlets especially like foreign
the gimlet for a long time used to be a
drink for like uh older widows yeah who
by the way when you you have to lose the
husband to get one of these yes uh and
you have to have a pearl a large pearl
necklace made with that uh husband's
life insurance yeah
so
[Laughter]
um
we used to order if like I remember
going to bars with girls and we were
like you know we're all kids and you
know [__] bars but the girls would
order gimlets to sound old ah so they
wouldn't get carded I want card someone
ordering a gimlet yeah oh yeah exactly
that's what I'm saying so so it used to
be like a totally like at least up until
like the early 2000s I would say if
you're very good it's like it used to be
like a very sour drink because they
wouldn't add any sugar at all because as
you get older your taste buds kind of
die out so you need more like zest more
spice more whatever just to feel it so
for example when I make like cause when
if I'm working a service bar if uh if I
get like a ticket for a cosmo I asked
the server like how old is the person
ordering this Cosmo because with a cosmo
you can balance it like very easily so
if they're older I always make it like
super sour and if they're younger
because like no but seriously and it
works that's exactly how they like it so
the the cut so yeah I just love that how
old are you bro
well that's why I asked the server not
them I'm like hey Miss
right um yeah yeah do you sound like do
you remember Bogart no uh but uh but
they used to be like really sour now
like we can actually make them to to be
like pretty palatable for everybody so I
think that's like a very well-balanced
cocktail well I agree with this help me
out here so I love tequila and sometimes
I get a lot of tequila sodas but
sometimes you want to mix it up and I
like a margarita but they're too too uh
sweet get a Paloma that might even be
too sweet but I want to order a skinny
Margarita but I sound like such a queef
ordering a skinny Margarita so what the
hell should I order I'm telling you get
a pool all right I'm gonna pull up a
skinny Margarita I know it's a lot of
cool yeah you can't think of BOGO man
give me a skinny Margarita give me a
mark you make a skinny yeah give me a
mug see
I'm watching my figure see all right
I'll get a Paloma a Paloma is really
nice because it's a grapefruit sour
anyway just say not too sweet you know
it's fine all right and it's super easy
they can make it at any Dive Bar most
people have grapefruit juice and what's
in a Paloma for juice slime tequila and
a little soda on top so the original
Paloma was made with like uh like
grapefruit soda that they have in Mexico
but uh
you know here we just do like soda water
and uh grapefruit juice little lime all
right that sounds nice it's really nice
I love it it's one of my favorite like
going like out drinks out because I only
drink tequila when I go out so
grapefruit juice is underrated I agree
completely good good versatile juice
I mean you know remember when I was
growing up every adult ate a grapefruit
for breakfast remember that a spoon yeah
yes there's a lot of cottage cheese I
think there's like a health craze my
grandparents thought [__] was healthy
that was not healthy though after eating
snack well or something like that [__]
[__] garbage yeah just eating shitty
cookies and they have like 10 of them
because they think they're healthy
exactly it's all sugar
this up
grapefruit in the face
oh yeah
very good
oh man everyone yeah
I'm sorry today to bring the room down
holy [__] hey no Jesus you bring the
room down with a spousal abuse Jesus
Christ oh he's like this will be funny a
woman getting beaten uh Cagney was like
a five foot two song and dance man it's
so funny that he's like a he's like uh
he's a Jew too I think right really is
that right unless you change his name
look it up he might have changed maybe
Edward G Robinson was Jewish I'm
thinking Robinson was a Jew so was
Jackie his name was Cagney Stern now
Cagney wasn't Jewish I don't think
oh maybe converted
Rod Kuru he converted
[Music]
um yeah he uh Irish American okay I
think Edward G Robinson was a Jew though
okay
Edition 1931 yeah what the hell yeah
he's just
puts another great food in someone's
face
[Laughter]
Cagney was great you ever see white heat
or Little Caesars
that sounds funny
is he a New Yorker
it must be I'm gonna go yes I think
everybody was back then
yeah he was uh Cagney's great I remember
seeing white heat on the big screen at
the Film Forum and that's a pretty epic
one top of the world my great movie
great movie I'll tell you I watched
Harold and mod on the flight back from
Hawaii classic that was Hawaii oh it was
great the shows were weird but they just
I was out there with Andrew Youngblood
we would just sit and watch the sunset
drinking High balls all day and uh we
got ATVs we went what swam it was great
it was a great time magical place it
really is the shows were weird but
magical place yeah I'm sure you're not
there for the comments yeah you don't
need comedy there like people came out
because they wanted to say to say hi and
support but like they're not Savvy you
know like there's a lot of heckling a
lot of woo a lot of like what we don't
care about that what are you doing jokes
about Uber
let's let's hang out let's drink you
know it was it was weird but fun hang
otherwise
we're in South Africa and Hawaii within
two weeks of it horrible routing I'm all
[__] up 11 hour flight there 11 hour
flight back I did I did Tacoma
mid-December in Washington I did Spokane
on New Year's I'm like oh this is the
same [__] far away state in weird
cities yeah back to back yeah
I had to go but what you need those days
home to recharge you really do you do
and it's like it's good and also it's
like staying out there you're just like
that takes more of a toll than than the
fight you mean that's true we're so
[__] up and flying all the time that
we're just kind of used to being jet
lagged so I think we're like kind of
used to it but you know it's funny how
our recharging is like I'm back in the
city I'll go drink midday on a podcast I
literally landed and went straight to
Colin Quinn show wow and then with the
bags no I I live walking distance oh I
dropped them off but I went straight
there took half a dump didn't even take
a full dump
I needed the bidet cleaning in my
butthole he just clipped I'm so used to
the bidet now I can't have an airport
wiping I need some water in my home
I went over there you spoiled [__] I
haven't spoiled my [__] become quite
a Dandy little [__] I went over there
and a Marlin and I you know we tie one
on at a whiskey bar nearby we have our
drinks I hope you [__] at the bar got
the rest out I waited till I got home
all right I want the [__] bidet oh
good boy you got a bidet at the bar
we'll talk we should have Marlin Craft
on he has his own mom's whiskey I told
him and he said he wants to come on
all right I want to try your bidet
you're welcome to come over it's a
heated seat too oh
I'm I'm more than happy to share with
anyone who wants to come over I I
Christmas day I had Jared freed uh my
friend Chase and my friend Dory over
watching Hoops eating Chinese food
pounding coffee before we switch to
Whiskey
we took two dumps he went back for
seconds on the dump before we went back
for seconds in the Chinese
wow and then uh yeah everyone took two
dumps it's a poo poo platter over there
well everyone you know everyone got
their you know you know their Chinese
and we switched to Whiskey pretty soon I
started making people Paper Planes there
you go nice it's a good thing you had a
good day be out of toilet paper
you save money on toilet paper and it's
eco-friendly eco-friendly those wet
wipes are the worst that's what ruins
the environment I got I got Greta coming
over to take a dump everyone's happy
how dare you
all right well thank you man this is
amazing Next Level this is excellent
you're you're great uh the hair the the
facial the you got some mitts on you you
could really chose a great head of hair
thank you really one of the best heads
of hair I've ever seen oh this is like
Jason Priestley in the 90s good yeah so
uh I I saw the patreon where you guys
were like reviewing reviewing us and you
guys just kept saying look this dude's
huge and I was like [__] do I need to
get like a muscle suit like I was like I
feel like I'm gonna be the only person
to ever catfish someone with an unedited
video of myself
you're good no no no it's I could tell
he was a he was a dude what's with all
the Alex Jones [__] you're looking up
Salamanca get him off with you goddamn
son of a [__]
oh no but yeah thank you for coming in
you killed it
I was gay I'd blow you
'll take it all right thanks for the
stogies
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay we're rolling Peters okay so uh
what I liked about the last guy
was he took his he asked where can I
take these glasses when he was done yes
and I remember hearing a story about the
CEO when he interviews you he brings you
into his office he says let's go get a
cup of coffee in the kitchen and you go
because you're trying to get a job and
then uh he brings you down and
interviews you and at the end of the
interview you shake hands or whatever
and if you don't take your cup back to
the kitchen and put it in the sink to
like do a little washout he doesn't hire
you no matter what your qualifications
are he's like it's just a personality
test oh I got like a decent person would
do yeah if you leave the cup there or
whatever
you don't get hired no matter how good
you are I mean support to be considerate
you know and especially like it should
it shows how much like uh I would say
like accountability there is you know
how much responsibility there is and and
that you're not pawning off like work on
other people just because like oh that's
not my that's the thing I hate worse
like I've trained I've trained like I
counted the other day I've trained about
like upwards of like 55 bartenders in
New York and they all have really good
jobs now and like that's the one thing
that like I will never let slide if
somebody says like oh that's not my job
like being a part
in a restaurant like if you're working
in a nice restaurant there's all sorts
of Staff right there's Runners buses
waiters Porters everybody right and the
bartender is kind of like up there right
like uh so there there are like a lot of
bartenders who will be like oh no I just
make the drinks I don't even go out from
behind the bar I'll never go into the
kitchen I'll never like touch it there's
two points to his penis that's not my
job he's like well you're fired
that's messed up no but it's like but
but that's that's the one thing that I
hate hearing the most is like that's not
my job like you know when you're working
with people especially in the
hospitality industry where everyone's
like so tight-knit like works together
to make in most places you pool tips
anyway you know like and then for
someone to say like oh that's not my
order that's beneath me well you're top
of the totem pole there and you're doing
humble exactly that's what I'm saying
yeah exactly and like but that's
important for everybody you know like
top of the totem pool doesn't mean [__]
when like the whole total pull is like
horizontally making the same yeah like
tips and everything so like just that
whole like yes there's a lot more ego
and like whatever like confidence in a
bartender like we're supposed to be like
the the face of the the the the bar or
whatever and we're supposed to be
talking customer customers and look nice
for whatever and have that like kind of
like ego trip and confidence just to you
know make sure that everyone feels like
we're in control nobody's like running
amok
button yeah oh oh geez you're wasting
good air with this [__]
stories 20 minutes long what are you
doing I'm just saying like it should be
we got it
ten minutes ago
right over [__] you
that's not my job I hate when somebody
says that there you go
I got it all summed up in one sentence
all right there you go I was like all
right I can't wait till we're back on
here I didn't know that was this was the
spot you're talking to me that whole
time
personally oh
all right how do you feel about both
those bartenders would you were there
people that you would uh hire at your
place you think yeah they're I mean
they're both great as far as bartenders
Scott was like very personal he's very
quick yes like
you know he just has to get comfortable
with like the stuff we have here and
that's it like uh Paulina was very like
uh on point with what she gave as like
the her personal cocktail you know like
she both knew you guys like negronis and
stuff and then put her own like cultural
spin on it with the Mezcal which was
fantastic very nice uh you know with the
gimlet he came out like the game was
kind of like not something that a lot of
people serve off the bat now but he made
a fantastic one great game you know uh
gimlet is an underrated cocktail yeah I
I really I've seen people order I've
never really ordered one yeah well the
divorcee lady thing maybe gave it a
little femininity so we were in a bar
and uh
I think it was uh it was Spokane uh
veteran at a bar and Vita doesn't drink
so I'm drinking at a bar and uh
uh the bartender walks over to us off a
drink and I was like and this pussy's
not uh gonna have anything the bartender
goes you [__] [__]
good to be the headliner can't catch a
break yeah does he must crack every now
and then and have a cocktail if his wife
is watching yes he does he's a bad boy
no he doesn't he never [__] does it
when I taped a special uh Chicago we did
four nights and I said you need a drink
with me I need your emotional support
this trip and he said okay so he got
drunk with me for that trip and the best
part is September 1st is when my Netflix
special came out and I was flying to
Vermont from Texas I have a bit about
this now about how I missed the show
that night because the connection got
[__] so I was really stressed I was
but then I was also like it's just a
show we're making it up on Sunday I land
in Vermont I said we're going to a good
restaurant we gotta like have a good
night show got canceled you got to get
[__] up with me and he goes you got it
we got [__] ripped and the next day
goes this is what hangovers feel like
and I was like yeah dude it sucks but he
hasn't like I'm used to it so I'm kind
of like yeah that's annoying yeah but he
it's been a while for him so he was like
are you [__] he was just mad the whole
day yeah and he's got a rhythm he works
out every day he eats well he goes the
rights and the hangers I take good care
of the little [__] yeah what does he
drink when he drinks for the first time
in a long time we were doing cocktails
we did some wine but he uh it's yeah he
really he really is like as the attitude
of a hot chick yeah well he's like you
better take he'll say you better take me
somewhere nice well it's easy when
you're eating off the kids menu yeah I
got a filet he got a dinosaur chicken
nuggets dinosaur chicken no he's looking
at some crayons before the food comes he
wants to draw on the tablecloth no he he
always says he goes you better take me
to this [__] restaurant like five
star restaurants you better [__] take
me there damn
yeah I was like we better [__] suck
me long time [__] and he does he
can stand and do it yeah
it's so funny that feeder I know we've
talked about veter for 30 minutes on
this up but he he sold Coke in college I
mean the guys he's got a rep he's got an
edge to him he wouldn't know it he's
this little guy with glasses but man
he's got history checkered that's his
show by the way yeah his beater is like
a drug mule
[Music]
and he's so good with business I bet he
had like eight you know freshmen under
him doing baggies and [__] laying it out
he's got the lady with no shirt on he
hits her ass you know
ooh
where are you gonna go coming up I'm all
over the place uh Dayton Toledo I'm
really running it through the mud here
uh let's see Spokane uh
uh uh Appleton Wisconsin
the uh Rochester
Poughkeepsie I mean I'm doing all the
fun cities big recording on March 18th
March 18th I think it's sold out we out
of the show so we might just keep adding
shows until we get as many as we can you
know can you say the venue the Vic
Theater in Chicago so sold out two
already well we might add one and
hopefully we had another four is a nice
number for a special that's amazing so
we'll see Chicago come on out got some
good food wrecks in Chicago please look
up Shaw's that's a [__] spot dude all
right also I mean if you want a great
what's the great burger spot in Chicago
oh something a you something
no ajoo but I love the odd juice what uh
the juice will not replace us oh
that's a good Prime uh rib spot yeah
better than our schwitz that's a whole
other one
um February 14th Salt Lake City is this
for Sam yeah bad Hotel New York Atlantic
City
uh Royal Oak Minneapolis we're adding
shows of all these places uh Madison
Wisconsin Milwaukee New Haven Boston
Miami Orlando Ponte Verde Beach adding
there uh Atlanta the Tabernacle uh
Charleston Durham Charlottesville uh
Norfolk DC we're on the tour bus for
this [__] stretches yeah
Wilkes-Barre PA ending that one in Port
Chester more dates being announced soon
but uh yeah a lot of cool [__] uh the
tour bus is just the truth it seems like
a lot of fun and I've seen the videos
and I it makes you want to be on it oh
dude I mean [__] with morning radio
morning press you know dead veter there
pretending to be dead we got uh we're
hooping every day we're being healthy I
mean we're getting lit up at night for
sure James Webb documenting all this
James has got some cool [__] he's got
some good footage of us hooping some
footage of us just you know pounding
booze and bars eating their good pizza
in Tulsa you know being animals on the
tour bus cool you know backstage stuff I
mean these theaters are beautiful it's
pretty crazy they have stories like you
know Houdini went through the ceiling
there and I'm like cool I'm gonna do a
dead baby joke right here different
vibes you know are you showering in
there I do yeah because we're on the
tour bus uh so yeah we shower at the
venue every night uh what's the pooping
on the bus situation you can't poop on
the bus no pooping on the bus they would
although the driver told me he goes it's
a girl here you know years ago and they
were just pooping trash bags what
you have to get rid of them I don't know
you just put up a trash bag uh where the
bowl goes yeah
[__] in the trash bag as you're sitting
on it
I don't want the seafood on that bus
we're doing [__] I was like no fish on
the bus is that your ruler or the bus
driver's rule no you can't poop on there
it was rural though I think it's the you
just can on those it's gonna stink and
if you see those toilets on the bus the
the hole where the piss goes down is
about the size of a quarter yeah so if
you drop a log in there it's sitting
it's sitting
it'll stew it's a stew it's a bad stew
yeah a pressure stew raise your [__] on
the bus because he was the headliner so
he should we you know we allowed him to
[__] on the boat what are we gonna say
and it didn't go down and we just had to
live with it so we're all peeing on his
rock hard Blue Ribbon can [__] that was
just sitting in the bowl for three weeks
Bird's poop has got to be the most
unhealthy poop even if it's orange and
just being like ah it's got a Hawaiian
shirt on Joey Diaz was like I'm getting
a hotel that was it really this guy's
been he's like a nam you know he's like
I can't handle this is too much it was
in New York in the 70s yeah yeah exactly
I think I'm not dealing with this tour
bus now the bus and these theaters are
just are legendary like you're literally
yeah performing where you're looking at
the other people on the wall or the
people standing the wall and it's like
crazy wild they're like always [__] in
this uh broom Claws and you're like
yeah get an innovator
you better earn that free meal bar yeah
you got anything there beard you're so I
didn't mean to call you out I just I
didn't know we were recording I feel bad
it's all good it's all good no I mean
the only thing I got is uh I'm gonna be
traveling for a little bit so if
anyone's out there uh who's listening
who's in
um Malaysia Singapore
Indonesia Vietnam Cambodia Taiwan and
South Korean Japan South Korea would be
the best actually because I have no
contacts there how do they contact you
I'm either actually I got I got a uh
Instagram so North Korea what do you
think sugar level 2192 if the
opportunity comes up yeah all right I
wanna I wanna meet uh Dennis Rodman uh
is he still there
um I don't know he I think I think he
left but he's been hanging out there for
a while but no a bunch of people already
contacted me through Instagram and
they're like hey I'm in Taiwan like I
love the show like come out like and I
love that because I'm traveling like
basically alone meeting people along the
way so I'd love to you know meet
somebody either transplants or locals
whoever and uh like find some stuff so
wait hit me up all right hit him up
we'll see you all in hell thanks for
coming whiskey.com get your Bodega cat
that's how we're making all these drinks
yeah the boys are some fun whiskey yeah
good for your family good for your
children give you give your kids some
Bodega cat whiskey and if they can't
handle it call them a [__] and beat
them yeah or take a cat whiskey not just
for adults anymore
yeah and uh get a glass and thanks to
the bartenders who came in and we'll see
the next bartenders next time get a
glass and tap that ass yes
[Music]
I've had a
handling much person and Norman's
talking [__] about the [__] post and
I get down in the same way
dangerous
[Music]
I'm out to lunch here in New Orleans
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same way
[Music]
alive
foreign
[Music]